gone vsoka when a friend says they've
never seen anime I show them this fight
this was the exact moment that I fell in
love with Hunter Hunter up until this
fight I really liked Hunter Hunter this
is pretty cool but this is where the
commitment was made to see it through to
the end this fight was especially well
done in the 2011 anime with inspired
cinematography and some of the best
sound design that I have ever heard in a
fight period it's crazy but like the
choice of where to use sound effects and
where to take advantage of Silence gives
us a real like hold your breath kind of
moment and Hunter Hunter is packed with
fights that are permanently burned into
my mind brain karapika vs zubergine
natural vs meruem and crawler vs hisoka
and the manga to name but a few but I'm
not interested in them today I've talked
about those fights to death and I will
probably continue to talk about those
fights to death until the channel ends
but what if I told you that you could
remove all of those key battles from
Hunter Hunter and the series would still
serve as a master class of fictional
combat because you can almost every
fight in Hunter Hunter is absurdly well
crafted designed a lot less to showcase
facing a stunning punch fighting but
intended more to explore certain ideas
so I asked all of you in the community
section what your favorite fights in the
series were and I have picked the most
obscure to highlight by the way if you
want to know how to join these Community
sections and be featured in these videos
then you just need to join our
association by subscribing to the
channel it's just one button and I
promise all of the Glorious Hunter based
content in return but let's get into it
gone vs gen through is highly underrated
I agree even though I'm admittedly one
of the people who tends to underrate it
this is one of the exceedingly rare coin
flip fights in Hunt Hunter most battles
in the series are very lopsided with
outcomes determined from the very
beginning but this one really could have
gone either way because gone have a plan
but it could have and actually it did go
horribly horribly wrong I think this
fight is a well-earned exhale for gone
though because at this point gone had
been training and generally being tossed
around for about 200 chapters so it was
pretty amazing to finally get to see a
protagonist step up and take on an exam
more suited to his particular level it's
very very much a case of exceptionally
talented amateur versus more standardly
talented veteran and who prevails
experience or raw talent although to be
fair to gone it wasn't quite as simple
as that this fight is likely underrated
because of gen through he's a well he's
one of the less memorable villains in
the series and so this fight very much
gets dropped to the bottom of the Barrel
in favor of other more much more
appealing bouts but the fact that
genther was here almost doesn't matter
because this fight is all about gone it
showcases all of his strengths including
intellect Instinct and most impressively
The Willpower to continue fighting after
his arm has been completely blown off
gone has to overcome the problem that
he's basic his Rock technique only works
in a very straightforward situation so
this fight is less about physicality and
more about tactics and positioning
everything gone does is in service of
trapping gen through within gone's range
and to that end he uses environments he
uses cards and like any masterful chess
player gone makes sacrifices to ensure
Victory I mean if Gunther were more
meets him villain then this would be a
fight that no one would ever shut up
about it's simply that brilliant gone
and his absolute finest for the first
and arguably last time in the series
even though kilowatt isn't my favorite
character I love when he finally removes
illumi's needle and smokes the rabbit
hand ah so this is actually a very
similar situation to gen through this
fight is underrated because of the
opponent Vermont again not one of the
more classically memorable villains of
Hunter Hunter but also he's completely
irrelevant because this isn't actually
kilowa vs remote it's more like Killer
versus kilowatt or even kilwa vs illami
to some degree remote is just the
inciting force that makes kilwa finally
confront himself and the best part of
the fight is that it pays off kilua's
entire character Arc up until this point
it retroactively explains illumi's
hypnotic spell from the hunter exam as
well as killerwa's careful Instinct
through the series but it also mixes in
the ominous warning given to kiloa by
bisky and it all plays out in the
context of kilua's desperate desire to
protect bestest body gone while he's on
a lovely date with a woman who should
potentially be arrested and charged with
grooming because gone is 12. but that
doesn't matter because kilwa is still
here to support his best friend and his
coogly inclined Tendencies I mean that
aside this is what solidified kilowatt
as my favorite character something I
really love is the moment after ripping
the needle out of his head because from
that point on kilowatt is overcome with
an emotion I want to say it's happiness
but I also think that's under selling it
because this is the moment where kilwa's
life suddenly makes sense to him he's
figured it out and there's this wave of
relief I suppose even though he's
mid-combat it doesn't matter because
finally everything is clear and under
control which killer then goes on to
demonstrate by instantly decapitating
Vermont going on to prove that his
presence there was never the true fight
ramot was a narrative tool a pair of
story tweezers to remove a needle but
like a really good pair of tweezers
solid craftsmanship that definitely got
the job done shoot vs up is so
underrated no one talks about it I
actually once considered making a whole
video in shoot versus yupi and they
they're still kind of van because it is
a genuinely brilliant fight
unfortunately it happens to feature two
characters who I would describe as of
lesser Prestige when one is looking for
something to click on so I don't know
how I'd effectively sell it as a
thumbnail but look that's not your
problem we are here to talk about a man
with two legs versus an ant with many
arms I honestly didn't really care for
shoot too much before this conflict and
to this day I still think that of the
extermination team he's a little bit
criminally underexplored but with that
said this fight sets the tone for the
palace Invasion very well specifically
by inverting the skills and the needs of
each faction shoot needing to become
more animalistic in relying on Instinct
as opposed to being crushed by his
severe analysis paralysis meanwhile on
the other side you've got yupi who
serves as a giant ball of instinct
needing to actually learn to incorporate
some sort of thought into his actions I
really love the moment where shoot
covers his eye and then the answer as to
why he does it is just I don't know no
reason no clear reason but that
epitomizes Instinct you can't always
assign a logical reason reason for
Action in these kind of situations
there's some speculation that even
though shoot didn't purposely do this
his actions resulted in a nen
restriction that allowed him to push his
abilities further than ever before or
another idea proposed is that removing
depth allowed shoot to view the world in
a much more simple and digestible way I
don't know how much I subscribed to that
because in depth is really important but
also there's the thought that this was
just an objectively bad thing to do it
gave shoot no physical or Aura benefit
whatsoever but what it did give him was
pure confidence even if he made the
wrong decision shoot made that wrong
decision with confidence which was the
only thing that allowed him to fight
against yupi for as long as he did which
to be clear wasn't very long not very
long at all like a couple of minutes at
most but look the length doesn't matter
because shoot had the girth to back it
up he achieved more in those few minutes
than he had previously throughout his
entire life and seeing this Evolution
from self-loathing coward to Brave
confident combatant was a glorious thing
to watch and not only is this fight on
underrated but shoot is heavily
underrated as a character you really
could analyze this fight panel by panel
and word for word there is there's a lot
in it tagashi did what tagashi does and
Hyper focused on an idea and then
executed it flawlessly 100 zoldx versus
crawler what I would call the first
exhibition of a professional Hunter
fight so despite the fact that neither
zoldx nor crolo are Hunters I agree with
that statement essentially this is the
first moment where we get a glimpse of
the power ceiling of Hunter Hunter which
comes at a very interesting time because
the previous Arc Heaven's Arena was more
or less a nen tutorial it took a lot of
meticulous time to introduce us to the
very Basics which is juxtaposed very
starkly against York new city where we
see those Basics and more applied in the
hands of world-class nen users and it's
definitely more than that because they
were doing stuff in this fight that we
weren't even aware of at this point like
crolo's ability we don't find out how it
actually works until long after this
fight happens so there's a certain
degree of Aura have watching xeno's old
dick swiftly unravel crawler's ability
and even though he doesn't understand
the exact specifics he still infers
enough to hard counter it and I really
like that we didn't get the standard
Shonen thing of Xeno you know dissecting
and then explaining crawler's power
verbally to us as the readers or even
worse crawler having some kind of inner
monologue explaining how skill Hunter
works and going cool I hope he doesn't
do that because my condition is this
yeah there's like none of that instead
tagashi dumps the explanation on a
Slater on a cover page and it turns out
Xeno was pretty damn on the mark more so
than anything else though this is the
fight that defines the entire zodiac
family which can be summarized in one
word that word being professional they
were hired to kill crawler and in the
space of mere minutes they came up with
a plan to do just that one of the
world's best nen users just snuffed out
in no time at all I mean yes it was
likely going to cause xeno's life to
enact it but that shows the zoldic
commitment to the business they accepted
the contract and will carry it out no
matter what the cost and it's fantastic
that this fight only ends because
another business transaction was
completed and then there's a revelation
that all three of them knew that this
side job existed and was likely going to
render this job irrelevant and yet Xeno
and Silva still gave this job the utmost
professionalism zeldick customer service
is so far off the chance that it
probably resides on the Dark Continent
although that's why they cost the GDP of
a small nation to hire because they are
the best of the best and this fight
tells us everything that we need to know
about that family with that said I'd
still like to know more a lot more every
fight with hisoka in it excellent that
that's wonderfully specific so I'm going
to take the liberty of choosing hisoka's
most obscure fight so you may remember
this or you may not it's one of the
earliest fights in Hunter Hunter where
hisoka faces a character named tugari
and trick tower tagari being an examiner
from the 286 Hunter exam who hisoka
tried to kill and in fact delivered
togari's visible facial scars this guy
is the whole reason why hisoku is even
part of gon's exam hisoka was supposed
to pass last year but uh he went and
attacked an examiner which is a great
way of building hisoka's character the
idea that he is both so powerful and
gives so little [__] about examiners
shows that hisoka is something very very
special particularly with how quickly he
dismissed togari going on to decapitate
him which is actually the second
decapitation that we've encountered in
this video but it builds a very solid
foundation of beer for hisoka one that
is very present in future events like
say gone vs his hisoka one of my
favorite fights in Heaven's Arena we
know that God has no chance in that
fight no chance whatsoever and we or at
least I feel genuine fear for him and a
lot of that is in great part due to this
early demonstration but let's also stop
and think about this for a bit it's not
apparent when you're first watching it
or reading it but hisoka killed not only
a licensed Hunter but an examiner
meaning that togari was an end user and
a pretty damn good one in theory I will
say that this is a really solid argument
for the theory that none didn't exist in
early Hunter Hunter because this fight
features not a single drop of implied
oreuse at least not from tagari anyway
could maybe argue that hisoku is using
enhancement when he catches the blades
but togari tagari's got nothing also fun
fact in the 1999 version they demote
togari from an examiner to a participant
because his dialogue States I didn't
come here this year to pass the exam
which when I saw that I was like good
you shouldn't have you don't need to
you're a licensed Hunter you fool and
it's an example of a change the 1999
anime did that I think actually makes
the series make more sense in retrospect
although they do have this hilarious
moment where tagari is juggling his
blades which looks so embarrassing and
not at all intimidating when looped as
they do so like
I don't know what that was 2011
definitely did a better job of making
him look like an actual threat but all
three series did a fantastic job of
having this fight so if hisoka without
this conflict hisoka would be missing an
integral building block making this a
highly underrated fight and let me know
in the comments if it wasn't in this
video what do you think is the most
underrated fight in Hunter Hunter